Speaker 1: We start today with the humiliatingly
abortive presidential campaign announcement
of Republican Florida Governor Ron DeSantis.
This event was a global humiliation, and if
Desantis's presidential campaign is going
to follow the theme and tone and competence
of yesterday's Twitter space, his announcement,
it is going to be a very, very short lived
campaign.
Now, let's not judge at all by the first 24
hours, but it was really bad for those of
you who don't know, There was an announcement
made two days ago that Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis, after much speculation, would indeed
announce that he is running for president
in the Republican Party against Donald Trump
and Tim Scott and Nikki Haley and Vivek Ramaswamy.
And he would be making this announcement alongside
Elon Musk on Twitter spaces.
Twitter spaces is a very rudimentary I mean,
we're talking about audio over the Internet.
This isn't the most advanced, you know, 4K
live streaming video you could imagine.
So low energy, nearly a dozen technical disasters.
I'm starting to think prayer may work because
I was willing technical disasters into existence
all day yesterday and they happened.
So I have to reconsider.
Maybe thoughts and prayers actually do have
an impact.
I'm kidding.
Of course, this was the worst and most embarrassing
presidential campaign launch that I can remember
in the modern political era.
Minutes of silence, random throat clearing,
muffled commentary from Elon Musk about how
the servers are melting down.
DeSantis himself getting booted off of the
event.
Let's just listen to a little bit of it.
And again, there are going to be extended
silences here.
I'm trying to get everybody back in the mode
of understanding the environment yesterday,
which we live streamed and just everything
going wrong.
Let's jump into it.
It is now live.
Okay, So it's starting about 8 minutes late.
And this is the sort of thing that we experienced.
Speaker 2: This through the year 2000 people
are.
All right, great.
So let's see if I just do crashing here.
I think we've got a just a massive number
of people online.
So its servers are straining somewhat.
Speaker 1: It's not clear.
They know they're live right now.
That's Elon Musk, by the way, speaking.
It's shocking to me they didn't bring in Mike
Pillow's cyber guys to help.
Speaker 2: Mm.
Speaker 1: Take it all in, my friends.
Take it all in.
Normally the this the David Paxman show doesn't
include such extended silences, but the content
is the silence in this particular case.
They seem to have no idea that this is all
live.
Okay.
It got even worse.
If you can believe it, when they sort of,
like, got closer to actually starting.
Speaker 2: Let's say so.
Yeah.
Like I said, just to simplify that.
Speaker 1: So then they cut out.
When they seemed to realize they were going
to be starting, they cut out again.
This went on for about a half hour.
Speaker 2: I think we're just going to use
your.
Speaker 1: As you can see, it's just not good.
Okay.
And then there were like audio feedback loops
and all sorts of things.
Now there are.
We're going to get to the DeSantis speech
in a moment.
There are people like Ben SHAPIRO, right wing
columnist, commentator Ben SHAPIRO saying
things like what he tweeted, quote, Tonight
was a perfect encapsulation of the campaign.
If you're obsessed with the optics of the
Twitter spaces glitch, then you're probably
not going to vote DeSantis.
If you're interested in political substance,
DeSantis is likely your candidate.
There were also people on the right saying
this isn't a disaster.
This event was so popular that it crashed
Twitter server.
So many people were interested that it crashed
Twitter servers.
It is a big success.
All of these narratives are idiotically wrong.
First and foremost, once DeSantis started
speaking, it got even worse.
He read a prepared speech with absolutely
no charisma or engaging inflection or delivery,
which just talked about woke, and he whined.
So once DeSantis started speaking, there was
no substance.
It was just grievances in an even whining
voice than the one Donald Trump speaks in.
And for this entire like it wasn't a disaster,
so many people were interested that it crashed
the servers.
This is a success, number one.
Not even a million people.
This was promoted for 30 hours everywhere.
Nationally, every played.
Fox was talking about it.
CNN, MSNBC, every newspaper, everybody was
talking about this.
And they scrounged together at its peak, 900,000
people.
That's not exactly a rousing success.
And the whole story about Elon Musk's takeover
of Twitter is he's the tech guy.
He's going to rebuild the stack.
Remember that?
We're going to rebuild the stack completely
from the ground up.
We've we've gotten rid of all of the superfluous
engineers.
Now, Twitter is operating beautifully.
This is just audio over the Internet.
It's not even video.
And they couldn't hold it together.
So the it was such a success that it crashed
is not a viable line now.
DeSantis eventually did start speaking and
he somehow figured out a way to be even more
whiny than Trump during his campaign launch,
which is really bonkers stuff.
He used the word woke, I think, more than
20 times.
I lost count.
Our live audience lost count.
Here's sort of what the speech sounded like.
Speaker 2: Biden's allowed woke ideology to
drive his agenda.
We will never surrender to the woke mob and
we will leave woke ideology in the dustbin
of history.
Speaker 1: There you go.
So woke, woke, woke.
You know it.
Remember when Rudy Giuliani was 911?
Noun verb.
Ron DeSantis is woke.
Noun.
Verb.
That's what that's what it is.
A humiliation for Elon Musk.
That cannot be understated.
Nothing worked.
And once DeSantis actually got to speak, it
was the lowest energy campaign announcement
I could imagine.
The political alliance also shouldn't be ignored.
Elon Musk, who says his number one priority
in buying Twitter and making the changes to
Twitter that he made is free speech.
And he's making a big show of celebrating
Ron DeSantis, who is quite literally banning
books in school libraries and suppressing
the speech of teachers and corporations in
Florida.
That's the alliance that we have here.
This event was so bad, even Donald Trump looked
clever and funny in trolling DeSantis and
I want to talk about
that next.